you think either candidate has a good
enough policy on trade that you know
that's a that is one of the naughtiest
ones trying to get in to the TPP weeds
where's your bridge I think I think
Hillary Clinton got a much better idea
what we need to do to me was it for it
before she was against well but Donald
Trump didn't care about trade five years
ago he's pro-choice five years of
further who knows what he's for but he
doesn't understand what TPP for it
against it uh uh actually I think I
would vote for you work yeah III think
it's less than TPP to me is more about
bringing nations into a set of rules
than it is about trade I think you know
it is one of those issues where I'll
read one article and go I'm for it and
then I'll read another one ago I'm
against it well no matter what you do
with trade the problem is we do not have
a good safety net that works for working
people their pensions their pensions are
going down they're big client number
people that have health insurance a
number of people have high deductible
health care plans and and so they do
look at trade and they say it's kind of
it's going to lower my wages they look
at immigration they say the same thing
they say the same thing about
technologies so they're not wrong right
well I don't think they are wrong but
but I don't think if you set price
controls and do all the things you think
you'd need to do in reaction all you're
going to do is drive down quality and
drive up prices I think you need a
different we needed a safety net that
took care of 65 year olds in nineteen in
1965 we need something different today
we need for younger workers who are
basically getting screwed okay should we
have confidence and the ability of polls
to predict the outcome of this election
oh yes I'm still nervous and I will be
no we should have known it Rex it didn't
win we're exit did not win the poll all
the polling mechanisms are changing
people people declined to answer polls
there's over polling people are sick of
being asked right also you're talking
about a shifting electorate and electric
that an electorate that is shifting so
swiftly there's massive voter
registration drives people dropping in
and out of interest and participation
engagement with the election I don't
think I don't think we should trust
polls I mean it could be a landslide for
Hillary there could be a lot of people
out there who just are not letting their
voice be known
we've never had round up all those
people and take the
out of the country on the ballot before
and right people like that
yes we've also Nazis never had a woman
on the ballot before ever and we don't
know we just don't know we don't know
[ __ ] here in Los Angeles we talked about
the Tom Bradley election Tom Bradley I
know what people don't know a lot of
people told the pollsters oh yes I want
to vote for a black mayor this is the
early 90s and then when they got in the
booth they decided they didn't right and
you worry about that with I mean the
polls look good for Hillary but Jesus
Christ she's she's also I mean a
terrible candidate like she's got to
stop saying at the debates go to Hillary
Clinton calm don't say that
say it to his face he's right there say
you're full of [ __ ] you [ __ ] don't
say go to Hillary Clinton duck distress
I agree with you please stop saying
Hillary Clinton calm yeah ever you had
the peril of Hillary Clinton turning to
Donald Trump and saying eat [ __ ] [ __ ]
is so high the amount of pressure women
don't get to express their anger that's
why I'm still good I really like her
okay that's what the village okay but
even split the difference
did you see how controlled she was yeah
it was heartbreaking and you know what
one of the ways Andrew said earlier
we've had a hard time remembering that
she's a woman because she's so firmly
you know identified as part of the
establishment we forget that she's this
outsider one of the impact one of the
effects of the past week has been
watching this woman this but whatever
you think of her overqualified
overachiever woman in contention for a
job against this know nothing sexually
predatory lout and watching that woman
have to compete with him as if this is a
normal situation in which he is he's
intimidating
what was more frightening right after
the debate to hear the media people go I
think Donald Trump did himself a lot of
good tonight right the rapists racist
did himself a lot of good look surely
lost Rebecca she lost on all the issues
she doesn't have a good answer on these
issues she's incapable of really she can
give you a laundry list she can give you
a laundry list but can she communicated
to people can she tell us what she wants
to do as president no she can't well she
does and realistic you know effectively
not effectively because she can't she's
too deep in the weeds she she knows too
much about the policy she's how this is
what I was saying about women suddenly
she's gonna be good by her and she's
gonna be good at the job she's not good
at running look you sure that's funny I
don't see watches can I oh by the way to
your question my answer absolutely not
all polls you can count on but but right
now Hillary Clinton's got a lead she's
got a lead as a consequence of this tape
as a consequence of people discovering
who Donald Trump is they don't like who
he is she's got a 19 point margin right
now with 51% of the population we're
going to vote or women and it's not
brexit we're identifying our voters were
going after our voters we're not doing a
very good job in Iowa by the way on that
score really we're not doing a very good
job and I'm doing a very good job in
Ohio a very good job in Florida we're
winning Pennsylvania the polls are
accurate in Pennsylvania Wisconsin in
Michigan I mean yes you got to go out
and vote maybe your vote doesn't matter
in California and mine doesn't vote
matter in New York but people sitting
out this election are making a big
mistake
but right now for all the right reasons
she's got a big lead and and I also want
to save it
well I inverse of the Bradley effect
which is Republican women telling
pollsters that they're gonna vote for
Donald Trump or telling husbands or
friends that they're gonna vote for
Donald Trump and then going into a
voting booth and maybe voting literally
is another possibility at some level
this is people are people are pissed off
this is a change election she represents
the antithesis of change so she is she
is incredibly weak on the core
fundamentals in the show what would you
like her to change that she's not
changing she is she is just simply I'm
talking about being analytic here I'm
just saying from
most people she represents rightly or
wrongly the established powers have she
don't even the white help at like 4:30 a
man first of all poverty rates are going
down unemployment's going down after the
worst economic crisis since the Great
Depression what do you want to change
other than trying to do something about
income inequality I mean there are
things that we need to do this is hey
Sandra this was my point at the end of
the show last week our litter we did it
was saying the whole election for Donald
Trump hangs on this idea that America is
the wolves are at the door if you listen
to Donald Trump it's all gone to [ __ ]
but if you look at the statistics
actually things are pretty good violent
crime is down unemployment is that what
they consider full employment the stock
market is as high as it's ever been this
idea that America is hanging by a thread
is ridiculous what the Democrats should
do is is his counterpunch on that and
when he says America is going to [ __ ]
say it is not that's all in your head
you [ __ ] pant chitters so I don't
know I don't know why we should I don't
know why we need a change agent the
Queen's I'm going to keep going in the
direction we're going they're not gonna
let me do this I'll get about the future
let's not make a t-shirt you can do the
t-shirt the slogans of bumper stickers
none of that you get to do okay and look
at that look at that the platform that
Bernie Sanders held up we can say oh
there's no change here except that that
platform includes mandated paid family
leave it includes subsidized childcare
it includes a raise of the minimum wage
it includes immigration reform it
includes things that have not been it
includes the wanting to abolish the
height and Helms amendment includes it
includes progressive possibilities that
have not weak were like the third rail
five digits ago yeah but you have right
now she's saying go to Hillary Kelton
calm it's all in there I agree with that
she's not making that and I agree that
it's not she's a nurse or opposing you
know progress in politics is not usually
sexy it's not it's it's it's obviously
harder the possum I'm saying city that
people looking looking forward not past
their the reasons we talked about
tonight they're very insecure and
cared about where the global economy is
affecting them the way the culture is
shifting and they want they want to find
somebody who could convince the one who
like went to West Virginia and of course
it got all taken out of context and said
basically look Cole is not the thing of
the future as it shouldn't be we found
something better than digging up a toxic
black rock and burning it deal with it
I'm so sick so sick of bleep people
bleeding about their [ __ ] stupid jobs
get a different job than the worst job
in the world
and who and who would help you find a
different job Hillary Clinton is the one
with the detailed nerdy plan to take you
from the stupid job retrain you to go
into the new economy what do they care
about that you know I've got you to
preserve the job that will give me black
lung disease when I'm 40 not getting
black lung disease any longer you're not
gonna you're not gonna retrace there in
a mine you don't get black lung no not
any longer if you want it why what
happened down in the Mueller retrained
somebody's know if I if I have their
shin to know if I've been if I've got a
mining job my father's had a money job
my grant and you come to say to me I'm
gonna retrain you and you're gonna do
what make 12 bucks an hour working to
some service economy no you retrain you
maybe for working with solar panel
unlikely unlikely I don't know somebody
else up look I'm for retraining people
I'm for trying to go to the new I'm just
saying why do miners get upset because
they're gonna get left behind you know
what you're not gonna pillory galleries
husband sold that idea great I mean he's
a much better salesman but when he was
running that's what he ran on and he did
it great she's just not a good
salesperson well I'm done trying to
answer the sensible say people I'm
trying to simply say about things
question was about why do we think it
might be closer and one of those is
she's incapable of connecting with most
people her and that is 80% as a job of
President the United States I hate to
tell you that is a lot of it I agree he
doesn't have that connection no he has a
real connection with his supporters I
don't feel massive enthusiasm because
she hasn't oval eyes pebbles party and
that's what's very worries yeah is
because a lot of people don't feel than
me
well what they'll sleep in elect the
elections in the bag Trump's a clown he
could never win I hear this all the time
in Liberal California in there in our
bubble Trump could never win it could
never happen I don't believe it never
happened in your town you don't live in
America I go to America almost every
weekend I don't they're not the flyover
States to me I land in them
I hide go to Nebraska I talk to people
I'm telling you Trump could still win
yeah don't ever forget that
thank you everybody
[Applause]